SHARP.
I LOVE THEM ON THE ICE FROM THIR
BALL.E HIGH-FLYING
COLORADO AVALANCHE, GAVE UP TOO
>> Steve: TWO GOALS IN HIS FIRS.
HERE'S HUGHES ON IT FOR THE
DEVILS.
THE RETURN FROM JIMMYMYAREAS.
>>
OFFENSE.
>> Steve: JANNE LAYED IN THE SP
DAYS THE BOARDS.HUGHES, WORKS I.
BRATT FOR HAMILTON.
HUGHES  HAD A GOOD LOOKING POWE
PLAY WITHOUT DEVILS.
HERE'S L CONTENT
WITH HIS TEAM'S DEFENSIVE EFFORT
EARLY IN THE GAME, OPPOSED TOHE
IT ACROSS.
OFF THE STICK OF van RIEMSDYK
AND PUNCHED IN AGAIN. GEL
DEFENSIVELY AND WATCH MICHAEL
McLEOD HERE.
HEADS ONLY TWO DEVILS HAVE MORE
TEAMS CURRENTLY POSITIONED SIXTH
AND SEVENTH IN THE METROPOLITAN
DIVISION, BUT AULLS UP, SHOOTS.
A MAN CUTTING IN FRONT. HANGING
IN THE OFFENS
FISCHLER.
>> Ken: HE IS THE HOCKEY
HISTORIAN.
OH,
THE PUCK COMB CHANCES.
I DON'T THINK THE DEVILS DID
THAT.
BLACKWOOD MADE A WICKED WRIST
SHOT AND THE DEV FORE-CHECK, FL.
THE RETURN PASS FROM
BREAK.
THE REFS PLAYS THIS BACK, TY SM
ON THE PUPU SMITH.
HIS WRIST SHOT, SCORES!
DAWSWSUCKS
THROUGH.
THE PENALTY KILLS HAVE BEEN IN
LANES.
NO BIG
PAVEL ZACHA GOT A STICK ON IT.
TAKERALLY, JUST POKE AT THAT
PUCK.
HE GETS A LOT ON IT.
IT GOES RIGHT FTER THE COACH'S
McLEOD
VILS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
MAYBE ICE THIS GAME.
GETS PAST CARTER HART.
NOBO
BIG STOP BY BLACKWOOD AGAIN. NOS
TO POKE PUTS IT HOME.
MICHAEL McLEOD WITH PUT THIS IN
HIMSELF.